I want to start with Michael this is for
you uh next generation at DS9 are two of
my all-time favorite shows and I just
want to thank you for all the hours you
spent in that makeup chair to play Wharf
and I just want to say thank you my
pleasure it's my pleasure I really want
to start with congratulations I've seen
the first six episodes of Picard season
three they're fantastic
um I fans are going to absolutely love
them
um for both of you what do you actually
want to tease the fans about what's
coming this season oh what do we tease
um it's gonna be an epic adventure
um action-packed for our story
um oh what do you want to teens
um
it it is a a truly an arc
where and I always loved arcs and shows
where it starts one place and ends up
another place yes and it is we don't
know
where it's going
uh we hope it's a happy ending
but we we don't know okay and um and
that's the thing is that it's going to
be our characters are going to go
through
um an arc
and uh I've always found that
interesting and I think the fans will
too well said
yeah it's interesting because one next
generation was on uh there was no you
know season-long storyline like there
was minor things but it's anyway it's
very good but I want to actually talk
about the action a little bit
um and I'm curious how much time did you
actually have before stepping on set to
do some of your action scenes together
where you could rehearse because I and
I'm also curious because Michael you've
done action as worse before and how did
it compare now a few years ago did you
have more time now less time more time
it was more time yeah I mean we
literally were there on days that we
weren't working yeah
um going through the scene because the
scenes on Next Generation
were fairly short and even on DS9 uh
we're fairly short and very sort of
concise and you know and uh but these
were
um very long and involved yeah and they
were Central to the to the story yeah so
you couldn't really like go okay just go
over there and and do people throw a
dagger right you know and so we had days
where we would be I don't think there
was maybe one or two days where I was in
makeup but the rest of time we were
there we were there in our shorts and
everything and and um and that was our
first our first our first meeting was
doing stunt rehearsal so we hadn't even
done a scene together and that was how
we first we first met and it was cool
because there was These Guys these Sun
guys were just they're amazing and I was
kind of going well we'll see and then
they showed a scene where
um I I go in there and it's my reveal
and I watched their previous preview
yeah I went oh my God
that's so so that was uh it it's quite
different like I said this was a movie
um they shot it no like a movie but it
feels like it was a movie so you had
time to to really work on these scenes
uh the season is 10 episodes uh which
was your favorite of the ten and why I
haven't seen all ten yeah we haven't
seen all you've seen more than we have
um yeah I think I've seen five yeah I
think we're five right yeah but I have
not seen uh all of them yet yeah I know
which I know which I know there there
were a couple of scenes that I really
enjoyed
um
finally doing with Michelle yeah
there's a couple that are really you
know lovely yeah
I was just going to say that it keeps I
think six is fantastic but it just keeps
building right at the beginning it's
it's a very you know what I mean um yeah
uh well I definitely want to know um
Michael this is for you but what did it
mean to play Wharf again for the first
time I believe in like 20 years you know
did you ever think it was going to
happen again no no I did not
um I had
I had an inkling it might when JJ Abrams
was doing his uh Star Treks because
after our last movie I it was dead I
mean Paramount sold off all the pair the
Star Trek stuff and they were dead they
were done with it wow and JJ came and
said Lord I want to do a Star Trek and
they went okay and
um but um like we've said a bunch of
times you never say never anymore but I
looked at my watch the other day and
it's been 35 years Wow since I started
wow 35 years that's impressive
I have to stop there I'm just gonna say
thank you so much and congrats on what
I've seen which is a fantastic season
thank you very much so much